This morning
my toddler stumbled into my room
and her first words were PB and J.
So that's exactly what I got started on growing up.
I loved having fresh bread.
It was one of my favorite things.
So I get it
started by making a really simple sandwich bread
with some yeast,
water, salt, sugar, and flour.
Kneaded that until a dough formed,
and then let that dough rise for about two hours
until it doubled in size.
I started on my raspberry jam.
I use some lemon monk fruit sweetener,
but you can also use sugar
and some cornstarch to thicken it.
While that was going,
I started on my peanut butter.
I roasted all my peanuts in the oven
and then ground them up with some sea salt
until a paste formed.
You can definitely add honey to this if you want to.
I didn't today because the jelly would be quite sweet.
So by this time,
my brand was doubled in size.
So I punched it to release all the air
and then split it into
rolled that out
and then folded that over to fit in my loaf pans.
I let that rest for another 30 minutes to about an hour
until it looked like a decent size in my loaf pan,
and then I popped that in the oven
and it came out so perfectly brown,
soft in the middle.
I was so excited,
I couldn't wait.
So I definitely sliced it a little Too early.
My daughter requested a mini PB and J.
I cut the bread down
and spread it with my peanut butter and jelly,
cut it diagonally,
and this was really good.
She ended up having a few of them and wanted more.